beautiful snow up in the mountains man
73 inches of snow now so far for the
season up there at lee canyon that's
great news of course getting some snow
last week our last week of 2021 it is
cold for our first monday of the new
year we're down in the 20s and below
freezing in many valley neighborhoods so
please make sure you've got a nice warm
coat gloves scarf even a hat keep you
warm this morning had a little breeze
out at red rock and some stronger winds
up at kyle canyon but also a little bit
of an inversion that's keeping some
warmer air in the higher elevations if
you are headed up to the mountain we're
looking at 42 degrees
sunny skies overall but i'm also
starting to see some of those clouds up
north that are just starting to glance
clark county so i think we'll see a few
of those clouds around earlier in the
day than we anticipated before partly
cloudy skies tonight so here they are
you can see them right now just trying
to slide through our area so i think
we'll have a batch of them a little bit
maybe through the morning hours then
sunshine and then more of those clouds
coming in tonight those are still
offshore all associated with another
strong system into the pacific northwest
we're not looking for rain we're just
looking for some clouds associated with
that storm up in the northwest boy
there's a lot of rain snow and freezing
rain all of this is barreling towards
the mid-atlantic states washington d.c
in the snow today in new york city as
well getting in on some of that but boy
even raleigh durham will be looking for
snow within the next hour or so and
those are freeze warnings across
southeast texas and the gulf coast of
louisiana after temps in the 80s last
week for the last week of 2021. so 51 is
what we're aiming for for us in las
vegas officially up from afternoons in
the 40s
for the first weekend of the new year
clouds tonight and then mostly sunny
tomorrow we've got a steady climb an
increase in temperatures thawing out
through the week thank goodness mornings
will get milder as the afternoons warm
up even into the low 60s for thursday
friday that's nice looks like that will
hold on pretty much through the weekend
those mornings into the low 40's more
clouds around for sunday maybe two on
monday